hello
nice one yeah I'm gonna shoot through
these water please
this is FPS England yeah not quite as
good but these are full of water and
hopefully we'll get slowed down as it
goes through each one I don't think it
should be able to hit each one a chance
to slip years in the army this actually
failed experiment we did this about a
year ago and this happened to her really
yeah oh no way good shot okay see what
yeah sweet nice awesome
that's pretty cool is that full speed
yeah it looks it's still ready sure
that's really fast in it well that was
actually a lot cooler than I thought
it'd be that's actually a really
powerful gun I'm quite scared it's quite
pretty yeah yeah yeah I get off sections
on sorry but the bullet was really fast
yeah we couldn't see it slow down talk
yeah bigger balloons higher frame rate
we're shooting this all very weird
resolution at 7,500 frames a second
which is 300 times so it's 300 times
slower hopefully we'll see a bit more
let's do it my slowdown in balloon as
well yeah that's what that's what noise
is gonna make is it I love how all these
videos all I get wet so that four
seconds that we just shot is now 24
minutes like that it's impressive
alright stop
yes
so the big balloons were too much that
small pellet to get through breastbone
is too strong I think bounced right off
that most balloons but then it slowed
down just right we are so much done so
technically this balloon has deflected a
an air pistol oppressive but I've got
two blues here we've gotta get rid of
them somehow so I'm thinking some sort
of movie style diving gunshot oh yeah so
I proved definitely yeah don't fire
until both your feet off the ground I
want you to be like diving like this
honey I was on to don't half-ass it
because if you're a [ __ ] about it
you're good for a long time really
come on okay ready yeah yeah yeah
you
you